[Musique]
je n'ai pas ma botte
le caire ville légendaire qui compte
plus de 1000 ans d'histoire
[Musique]
avec le temps elle a perdu du lustre et
gagner en achalandage se traduisent à
malines taxer les abats au tournoi
international la csd
rexel est aussi 23 millions de personnes
vivent dans la capitale et ses banlieues
l'egypte le pays arabe le plus peuplé du
monde et près de 2 millions de nouveaux
venus s'ajouter chaque annick le taux de
croissance de population est si élevé
qu'il constitue une réelle menace à la
survie du caire
[Musique]
mieux pas nommé
le gouvernement égyptien a donc
entrepris un chantier pharaonique
construire au beau milieu du désert là
où il n'y avait que du sable et des
chameaux une toute nouvelle capitale
stimuler son économie et surtout pour
s'éloigner du chaos du caire
le moteur cela équivaut à une fois et
demie la surface de toute l'île de
montréal
c'est le plus gros chantier d'afrique
est certainement un des plus gros au
monde
deux cent mille personnes travaillent
ici
une trentaine de ces immenses buildings
vont abriter différents ministères et 50
mille fonctionnaires mais le siège du
gouvernement ne sera qu'une petite
partie de la future capitale qui pour
l'instant n'a pas encore de nom de la
great games mais il ya une sorte d'art
mengo diplomatiques et à wigan
on a prévu aménager une quarantaine de
centres commerciaux des parcs des
espaces verts à perte de vue et surtout
d'immenses quartier résidentiel équipés
de technologies de pointe
de quoi attirer tout le gratin
immobilier d'égypte et de la péninsule
arabique
à
[Musique]
discret lors du baby boom
ce soir-là 1200 personnes ont répondu à
l'invitation des promoteurs d'un projet
immobilier de luxe incluant plus de 1700
appartements et centre commercial la
nouvelle capitale a beaucoup des points
d'attraction comme le nouveau à l'épaule
le siège du gouvernemental palais
présidentiel
le parc d'exposition et les universités
[Musique]
en plus des ministères des centres de
commerce et d'affaires des mosquées la
nouvelle capitale offrira un million
d'unités de logements pouvant accueillir
jusqu'à 6 millions personnes ça c'est le
projet dans les faits plus de résidents
de la capitale actuelle auront les
moyens de venir vivre ici
[Musique]
les critiques sont nombreuses dans le
pays
ce professeur émérite déplore que le
gouvernement égyptien n'est consulté ni
les experts ni la population avant
d'agir
ces projets bon il ya des appartements
qui coûte cher et puis il n'ya pas
vraiment des postes d'emploi pour des
gens honneur le prix moyen d'un
appartement de la nouvelle capitale sera
d'environ 100 mille dollars c'est une
somme considérable dans un pays où le
taux de pauvreté atteint les 30% et il
me paraît que les projets de
construction d'une nouvelle capitale ne
résoudra pas les problèmes de
surpopulation
ok mais le gouvernement prétend que la
classe moyenne égyptienne pourra
s'offrir une place dans ce nouveau
paradis mon seul homme seul mot sexe
pour relier la nouvelle ville au caire
on a déjà construit une autoroute à 12
voix une soixantaine de kilomètres
un train électrique et un monorail sont
aussi au programme
[Musique]
l'ensemble du projet est estimé à plus
de 20 milliards de dollars américains
je crée tant pis endettés notre dette à
l'étranger s'élèvent en plus de 100
milliards de dollars dans ces conditions
décidé de construire nouvelle capitale
qui exige quand même beau des dépenses
énormes en bon donc je pense qu'il faut
être prudent
à cela le gouvernement répond que tous
les fonds proviennent d'investisseurs
privés ont d'ailleurs cela crée des
symboles des architectes déplore
l'absence de style égyptien de la future
capitale
ils jugent sur l' architecture banal
calquée sur celle des villes modernes
occidental à leur époque les président
sadate et moubarak avait aussi souhaité
construire des villes grandiose sans y
parvenir
certains croient que le projet actuel
représente une sorte de bravade de la
part de l'actuel président choisit bien
mais bon ce n'est pas le président qui a
dit c'est le plus en six 6 qui l'a
décidé pourquoi tous les chefs d'état en
egypte rêve de laisser quelque chose
pour l'histoire la nouvelle capitale
devrait accueillir ses fonctionnaires et
ses résidents en 2021
un an plus tard que prévu pandémie
oblige mais pour le reste du monde
le caire restera sans doute la capitale
légendaire de l'egypte
[Applaudissements]
ramsès 2 toutankhamon devrait pas se
retourner dans leurs sarcophages
[Musique]